hi it's Michelle from Lab muffin Beauty
science chemistry PhD and skincare nerd
I've talked about the ins and outs of diy
hand sanitizers quite a bit but
another question that a lot of people
have started asking me is how do you
look after the skin on your hands when
you're washing and sanitizing them so
much? *I just want to be pure* how do you
stop your hands from getting so dry and
irritated? so I asked a bunch of
healthcare workers dermatologists
doctors and nurses including my mum for
their best tips on how to keep your skin
happy while doing your part to slow down
the spread of the virus and I'll be
sharing their tips in this video if you
like this sort of content give it a
thumbs up subscribe to my channel and
click the notification bell so you don't
miss any videos first off why do we care
about keeping our skin in good condition?
shouldn't we just be focusing on
sanitizing our hands as best we can?
after my videos on hand sanitizer a lot
of people were asking me why they
couldn't just use plain alcohol some
people even asked if they could use
plain bleach if they were happy to deal
the consequences on their skin but it's
important to remember that your skin is
your first line of defense against germs
not just the coronavirus but other germs
as well you don't want your skin barrier
to be compromised to the point where
germs can get in easily and cause an
infection
there's also the fact that cracks and
flakes in your skin are really good
places for germs to hide so you might
not be cleansing your hands properly if
your skin is damaged and of course if
your skin's damaged then cleansers and
sanitizers are going to sting a lot more
and that means it'll be a lot harder
to rub your hands with soap or sanitizer
for 20 seconds many times a day which is
what we should be doing to protect
ourselves properly from coronavirus if
you start getting severe dryness and
cracks in your skin that don't seem to
be improving with the tips here make
sure you talk to a doctor or
dermatologist and they can try to work
out what's happening and fix it but if
you follow these tips hopefully it
doesn't get to that point the first tip
for dealing with hand irritation is by
avoiding it in the first place by using
gentle cleansers and sanitizers almost
everyone I talked to for this video
mentioned this my mum's actually been a
nurse for 45 years and this was the main
piece of advice she gave for a while she
had really bad hand dermatitis
where her skin was cracked and raw
and inflamed even though she was using
tons of hand cream but then the hospital
changed their brand of hand soap and
after a few weeks she didn't actually
need hand cream at all different people
are sensitive to different ingredients
so it might be worth trying a few
different products to see which one
suits you best
my friend who's an anaesthetist mentioned
that her hospital actually supplies a
few options for people to choose from
when you're choosing a hand wash there's
a few things that you can look out for
to improve your chances of finding one
that will work for your skin you've
probably heard a lot about washing your
hands with soap and water but soap here
actually means any hand cleansing wash
true soaps are alkaline with a high pH
whereas your skin is low pH and acidic
this means that if you're repeatedly
using a true soap every day it will
disturb your skin's pH and irritate it
soap-free cleansers use synthetic detergents
and these generally end up less
irritating because they can be
formulated at a lower pH they still have
pretty much the same cleansing
properties as a soap they will remove
the virus from your hands and help it
wash down the drain they can also break
down the lipid envelope around the
coronavirus and inactivate it so choose
a cleanser with a low pH and make sure
it doesn't contain soap in the
ingredients list if you want to reduce
your chances of irritation in general
products with a shorter ingredients list
will give you a lower chance of irritation
than one with a longer list because the
chance of you being sensitive to any of
the ingredients is lower you might find
that your regular hand wash is actually
too irritating right now because you're
using it so much you can save that for
later and use something that's more
friendly for sensitive skin while you're
washing your hands a lot more some of
the very gentle cleansers that some
dermatologists have recommended include
QV soap free wash aquanil and dermal
500 a few tips for choosing a gentle
hand sanitizer studies have found that
isopropanol which is isopropyl alcohol
or rubbing alcohol is more irritating on
your skin than ethanol so choose a hand
sanitizer with ethanol if you can
sanitizers that contain moisturizing
ingredients like glycerin have also been
found to reduce irritation and dryness
on your skin different hand sanitizers
also have different ingredients other
than the alcohol and the moisturizing
ingredients so things like fragrances
and preservatives
and thickeners so your skin
might tolerate one sanitizer better than
another
just like with hand wash choosing a hand
sanitizer with a shorter ingredients
list will probably reduce the chance of
you reacting to a particular
ingredient in it a tip that you might
not have expected is that hand sanitizer
tends to be less irritating in the long
run than washing your hands if you're in
a position where you have to sanitize
your hands a lot like if you're
healthcare worker using a properly
formulated hand sanitizer with
moisturizing ingredients is generally
going to be less damaging than
continually washing your hands of course
this depends on the formulas of the
specific hand sanitizers and cleansers
that you're using but generally
sanitizing is better for your hands
because water is actually irritating
onto a few tips for how to wash your hands
don't use hot water for washing your
hands hot water strips your skin of its
natural moisturizing substances much
faster than lukewarm or cold water after
washing pat your hands thoroughly dry
with a towel rather than rubbing it's
important to get rid of all the water
you can because again water can be
irritating if your hands soak in water
for too long it can break down your skin
and patting rather than rubbing will
reduce irritation wearing gloves in
certain situations can also help it's
also a good idea to avoid getting your
hands wet outside of washing your hands
water is irritating and having your
hands wet for too long can break down
your skin barrier faster so you should
be wearing waterproof gloves when you're
washing your dishes dishwashing
detergent is designed to clean greasy
dishes not dirty hands so it's a lot
harsher than hand soap you also use it
for far longer than the 20 seconds you
need for effective hand-washing
waterproof gloves are also a good idea
when you're preparing food some food can
be irritating for your skin and having
the gloves there to protect your skin
means you won't have to wash your hands
as much when you're wearing gloves make
sure you change them if your hands get
wet inside the glove or too sweaty
because that water can break down your
skin barrier when you're doing housework
or gardening you can wear breathable
fabric gloves to cut down how much you
need to wash your hands it's a good idea
to avoid wearing latex gloves because
latex is a really common allergy if
you're in a place where it's cold and
dry Dr Anjali Mahto recommends wearing a
pair of winter gloves outside cold air
and exposure to wind can make
hand eczema worse using a hand cream is a
pretty obvious solution so here are some
tips on choosing a hand cream there are
a lot of good hand creams out there if
you haven't found a good one yet the
dermatologists I talked to recommended
fragrance free hand creams allergies and
irritation are more likely to happen if
your skin is already a bit irritated and
sensitive from all the hand washing so
avoiding fragrance and really any sort
of additional ingredient is a good
precaution barrier repairing ingredients
to look out for in hand creams are
glycerin and ceramides
Dr Adeline also recommends niacinamide
or vitamin b3 for reducing sensitivity
she also recommends hyaluronic acid
which is an effective humectant for
attracting water back into dry skin if
you're looking for specific product
recommendations a few people recommended
Neutrogena's Norwegian hand formula
there were also recommendations for
Vaseline Aquaphor CeraVe Cetaphil
Vanicream La Roche-Posay's Cicaplast
and Lipikar formulas and Bioderma
Atoderm Dr Aegean Chan also recommended
3M's Cavilon if you're looking
for a heavy-duty barrier cream it
contains dimethicone and it lasts
through several washes several
dermatologists also recommended using
petrolatum heavy products at night you
can also use these during the day but
they can be a bit sticky and greasy
another possible issue that Dr Adeline
pointed out is that petrolatum has been
known to weaken latex so if you're a
health care worker it's a good idea not
to use these creams before wearing latex
gloves a few tips on using hand creams
remember to apply the hand cream all
over your hands including between your
fingers try to use hand creams more
frequently not just that night but
regularly throughout the day it's a good
idea to keep a few tubes of hand cream
in different places so you don't forget
to use it so for example on your bedside
table next to the TV on your desk in
your car you can make a few sets of hand
cream with small bottles of hand
sanitizer if you have it so you can keep
a set in your car a set in your handbag
and a set at home so you don't forget
to take with you when you leave the
house for a deep overnight moisturizing
treatment you can cover your hands with
hand cream then put on cotton gloves the
gloves stop the hand cream from coming
off onto your sheets so that your skin
can soak it in more effectively if you
don't have cotton gloves
you can use socks Dr Papri also
recommends soaking your hands for 10
minutes in tepid water then pat your
hands dry and then put on the hand cream
while your hands are still damp before
you put on the gloves if you have cracks
in your hands a few dermatologists
recommend sealing the cracks up with
either superglue or liquid bandaid this
protects your skin and makes it a lot
less painful while your skin heals if
your skin does get dry and damaged and
flaky resist the urge to pick at your
skin this can make your skin feel worse
and open it up to infections
if you develop blisters Dr Joyce also
recommends not popping them because the
same thing can happen do you have any
other tips for looking after your hands?
share them with us in the comments I
hope you enjoyed this video if you did
you can like this video and subscribe to
my channel for more videos like this
thank you to all of the experts who
generously shared their tips with me
I've left their social media details
here so give them a follow if you want
more content on the science behind
beauty products you can follow me on
Instagram and check out my blog see you
next time for more nerdy beauty talk